if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
[Music]
which is just
in areas where there's tremendous
amounts of water where the water rushes
out to sea because
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to once
dumps dumps dumps
[Music]
what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
mangoes my bags are mangoes
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like 3
seeds
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
and highway robbery is what you're doing
[Music]
well welcome everybody uh oh no not
again no audio oh my god these people
don't know what they're doing with this
audio
i'm gonna have to fire everyone
oh am i on oh my god oh the no no
nobody's getting fired sorry sorry sorry
no that's a joke welcome everybody we
are standing by for president joe biden
why well record inflation we learned
today that inflation over the last 12
months 8.5 percent this is the highest
one-year inflation
since
1981.
now
i hate to even have to start with
sort of cow towing to the lowest common
denominator
but i have to
because there are people who think what
was announced today
was that in the last month prices went
up eight and a half percent now i'm not
blaming anyone
because you look at some of these
reports
and it makes it sound that way like look
at this this is cnbc or seeing book as
some people call it consumer prices rose
8.5 percent
in march
it genuinely sounds like they're saying
in a month prices went up 8.5
which is crazy
that's i mean you know we've seen that
in venezuela
maybe in argentina
you've seen it
uh zimbabwe
but what they mean is in the 12-month
period ending in march
prices went up 8.5
and it's like such a basic thing
and i don't only want to blame the
people who are mistaken because
this is like a pretty mainstream article
and it certainly makes it seem like in a
month prices went up
eight percent
so in any case they didn't
and initially the markets actually
reacting okay as you can see here we
initially had um an increase in the
price of stocks
but then now it is it is way down it's
just been a very big decline
and uh you know explaining why the stock
market moves many people have opinions
and um you know it kind of is what it is
but stocks initially up now are down and
joe biden is going to be addressing us
soon
um and telling us
that graph was 24 hours
um
no
this see how it started at 9 30 a.m
that's when the market opened today i
don't know what who who said it was 24
hours
who was that eddie styles first time
chat from eddie styles eddie i wish you
could have done better on your first
chat in my channel
as you can see here this is the trading
day at the bottom the way we read a
graph is we look at the a y and x axis
and as you can see it starts at 9 30 a.m
i don't know please do better eddie
please do do better
sad
okay welcome by the way thank you
so uh joe biden's going to talk to us
about the plan to lower costs of
different things now i know a lot of
people in the audience are saying but
david what about the price of mangoes
i am not up to date on the price of
mangoes but
no joke
yesterday you know this this weekend we
have passover coming pesach as we call
it
and um i went to get of course some
passover but kosher for passover matzah
and they were selling the big time stuff
for 20 bucks a box
and then some cheaper stuff for 10 bucks
a box
not good now i genuinely have no idea
what the normal price is but like normal
matzah is like three bucks a box this is
kosher for passover so they're probably
it's predatory matzah
um
yeah i don't know
and then uh that was disappointing i i
just bought a regular i just bought a
regular box i don't really care about
kosher it's just you know it's tradition
it's tradition as we say so we have
multiple streams here standing by for
joe biden and i think it's going to be a
very very big thing
now i do want to thank some really
really great people so many people
supporting us via twitch i want to say
thanks to roni's twitching nug wrangler
no roni's twitching with a gift weather
boxer tricia northstar
hot
and brankle brandleby
seven people
kicking us off today look at that look
at that oh beautiful
wow a lot of people are getting banned
that's that's pretty wild um already
the gifting of memberships i have a
beautiful update as many of you know we
have had about
750 people ask
for free memberships
okay 750 people asked
and so far we've had 117
memberships gifted on my website
so the ratio is starting to get in line
now a few questions i want to answer
some people have asked me
are the gifts monthly or yearly
memberships and the answer is
it's up to the gifter you can gift a
month or you can gift a year and it's
luck of the draw we just go in order so
you can't email me and say david i want
a gift but only for a year we just go in
order if the next membership is a month
and you are the next person who has
asked you get a month
if the next one is a year and you're
next you get a year it's too complicated
to do anything else okay so if you want
a free membership
go to davidpakman.com free membership
and fill out the very simple form it's
your name and your email do not email me
do not call me
okay you will not get a free membership
anyway other than just filling out its
three fields first name last name email
davidpakman.com
free membership
there is no other way to get one
and then if you would like to gift one
you just go to joinpakman.com
and when you're checking out there's a
box that says is this a gift
if it's a gift you check the box
is that fair do we understand that if
you're buying the membership for
yourself when it says is this a gift you
don't check it you just leave it blank
and if it is a gift you check the box
these are the full instructions okay
and it comes with three mangoes exactly
right
i got an interesting voicemail from the
eggman that i wanted to play for
everybody take a listen to this
it's espresso not expresso please eggman
i thought you were a man of culture
oh wait a second you guys can't hear it
oh hold on a sec oh god not this again
oh god not this again
let me see what we've got here
oh hold on a second
okay let me try let me try it from the
top here we go
hey dave when mike pillow sues your
espresso maker is he gonna call you for
a witness will you be subpoenaed listen
dave i know it's all joke that this
guy's nuts but this guy is nuts do you
think that at some point somebody should
step in and say to this man you need
medical help yeah this man is definitely
medically
sick of course
of course there's something wrong with
him i think he's back on drugs possibly
if you listen to the way the man speaks
the man speaks like he's trying to get
his necks fixed
and
and also do you think the people that
are there the conservative uh listening
to trump speak whatever do you think
they believe him or they just kind of
you know giggle along i think it's funny
because if people believe him that would
be even scarier than this man being this
sick
shalom brother
yeah
so um yes uh eggman is right mike pillow
does seem to be sick we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines
[Laughter]
exactly exactly very very much true
uh i want to say thank you to andrew
kulp
andrew kulp
just gifted a membership okay so that
was a gift
and
that is number eight today
and nick kelly
gets the membership
see how that works someone gifts
someone gets
someone gifts someone gets really simple
i want to also say thank you to kind af
elevated disc golf mitch potley
drewish
79 carlio
dilloner
milo wilde as well some twitch prime
subscribers putting us at 15 really
appreciate everybody's support on twitch
truly and uh truly and genuinely do
okay
let's get to some other things oh hold
on do i have any i guess i don't have
any super chats
um
wm black
has uh gotten a youtube membership but
no no super chats that's okay that's
okay but we're gonna continue here okay
i don't know how many of you oh wait a
second i have a bunch of different
things here our friend walter masterson
went to i guess this was an anti-vaxx
rally
and he interviewed people about their
research let's listen to this these are
facts go to the cdc.gov do not be a
science denier
but everyone here uses the cdc
statistics as a credible source
they don't use it as a credible source
go find me one single person here that
believes the cdc numbers are actual
where where can people go to verify the
numbers on your sign
you can go to the vares uh database this
you can go so you can go to the cdc
website like people just don't look at
the information but on the cdc website
and here's the url if you want to you
get all your information from the cdc
website but you don't believe the cdc
you need to understand there's a
difference between numbers being
reported and policy well you believe the
numbers they report no
underreported a lot of these numbers are
manufactured but where are the real
numbers
first of all you're not going to find it
at the cdc you can find it listen you
just told me to go to the cdc website
that's right they do tell the truth on
on the cdc website it's the mainstream
media that's manipulating it but we can
trust the cdc no
you can't trust them you can't trust the
cdc but
you can trust their website because
that's where the numbers are right and
the numbers don't lie
yeah so you know you just you got to get
your information from a lot of people
like you these are
pretty pretty clear stuff huh i think
that's that's that's some really nice
work there by our friend
uh walter masterson man that is
something i see some people with a new
meme in twitch chat which is bad news
with a question mark
and
this was i sort of had a faux pas
yesterday our good friend sam cedar
announced that he has the virus
and um where was it and
ty i i just constantly make typos on my
phone
and i accidentally wrote back bad news
get well soon like as if i was asking
whether that's bad news and like
obviously it's bad news that sam has
coveted so then i had to i try to avoid
deleting tweets because then people
start fixating on the fact that i've
deleted tweets so i then followed up and
said yikes i meant bad news with an
exclamation point on my android phone
the question mark and the exclamation
point are right next to each other
um so that was a that was a faux pas but
i did afterwards text with sam and we
you know i'm not going to violate hippo
by giving out his medical elements not
that i could i'm not a medical provider
but in any case uh
you know it's it's he's getting he's
getting the treatment that he needs and
we went over all of the details and we
we absolutely wish sam the best with
everything that is going on
um okay super chat's here are levers and
pulleys safe
wait a second where is this
there we go are levers and pulleys safe
from pillows war on machines we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines i don't know the answer to that
i don't know if a lever and a pulley it
is a sort of primordial machine of sorts
that's a fair point
wm black says it's william black
lol jenk does the same thing
oh like question marks instead of
exclamation points yeah i'm doing the
best i can guys with uh with typing it
can be tough i want to say thank you to
barb
fusco and lauren mcrae who have just
gifted two subscriptions on our website
putting us at 17 the lucky recipients
are christian mastriani you get a
membership
and kimberly gonzalez you get a
membership we are now down to
659 people waiting for free memberships
659
if you're wondering
wow if i gift a membership is there
anyone waiting yes there are 659 people
right now waiting thanks also to d4 real
physicist and ir geek for the twitch
prime subscriptions putting us at 20.
all right
there was an anti-vaxx rally
over the weekend this one was much less
publicized but i did do a story today
on the podcast and we'll have a youtube
clip released soon i'm just going to
show you guys a little bit um
lara logan spoke introducing a 14 year
old who then went on an anti-vaxx uh
diatribe
check this out for human and civil
rights
hold the
line
and for our children
hold
[Music]
[Applause]
does anybody know what mandates they're
protesting
[Music]
[Applause]
usa
freedom
[Applause]
so i was talking to those ladies back
there you know you don't want to be
friends with them they chained their
best friends to the capitol building in
one of their protests
oh my god
they've been arrested a number of times
so those are brave ladies right i mean
that's pretty extraordinary
okay so now there's a young man waiting
there he's by far the best rest at this
event today
and uh he's only 14 years old
and he's really it's really sad what's
happened to lara logan just completely
lost her mind nervous
but he's really prepared he probably did
more work coming here today than any of
us
and i asked him what's the most
important thing i need to know about you
and he said i'm a christian
and a fighter and a warrior and an
activist his friends don't talk to him
anymore his brother and sister think
he's gone crazy and if it weren't for
mom and dad he might not be here today
so please well yeah i mean in a literal
sense if it weren't for my mom and dad
he wouldn't be there today yeah that's
that's true welcome
on to the stage
a little man look at this called lucky
this is this kid is like trump check
this out
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
we are here in grand park los angeles
gathered do you want to know why we're
gathered here
because it's time to take back
this is a freedom activist
it's time we stand and fight
we cannot let the weaklings take us down
the brainwash will not defeat us america
will be shrunk again and california will
be liberated people
guys they're gonna liberate california
from what i don't know but it will soon
be free
our country is in peril deep peril our
constitution is being disregarded as
nothing more than a piece of paper and i
will not let it stand this kid has to be
a victim right in some like
let me just see if biden's up yet now
yeah uh we'll turn the audio up so we
don't miss it
it's hard to imagine this kid is
anything but a victim
this is not a democratic issue this is
not a republican issue it is an american
issue
freedom
all americans deserve to be free our
founding fathers founded this country on
the right to be free
if this if we were told that this was
satire we would all believe it right
like if i said hey guys check out this
incredible satire of like just a kid
spewing antibac stuff and like doesn't
even know what's going on we would all
believe that it's satire if that was the
premise i think
and i say take back our freedom now
i was kicked out of my school because i
did not get that vaccine now that
doesn't matter what matters is that i
have the choice why don't i have a
choice that is supposed to be entitled
to me as an american
what anyway so that's pretty vile let's
see um
there were some other really
inspirational speakers i'm just trying
to look through here
we've got a bunch of clips
on uh on a clip that's coming out
uh oh brett weinstein spoke let's see
what he had to say we must preserve the
gains of nuremberg liberate the practice
of medicine from the pharmaceutical
industry defeat the mandates and come
together as americans
good luck to you all
it's just it's kind of like a who cares
type of thing like you know
see who else was there
i don't know i don't even know who these
people are
let's see let's just see who this is
dr henry ely is treating the vaccine
injured
and what i want you to do is point to
yourself
excellent
most of you are pointing right to your
heart
you see
when we come together in love the
impossible becomes
possible
and
how many people think this guy is a
medical doctor versus some kind of you
know
naturopathic doctor i don't know who
this guy is i'm gonna look it up how
many of us think this guy's an md just
just take does anybody think he's an md
i don't know anything about him we're
going to look it up right now
all right let's check it out
here's his uh
oh wait a second
now let me find something else oh we
were going to get to jimmy dore next
hold on a second
let's see what we've got
doctorate in naturopathic medicine there
it is
it's uh
yep you guys called it
not a medical doctor
now strictly like it's it's not just
about an appeal to authority like oh you
should only ever listen to an md
but
it's like yeah okay anyway
he's not even a chiropractor exactly
exactly all right so we'll get to the
jimmy dore thing in a moment uh oh
here's a beautiful 20 super chat max
blumenthal spoke at this event i thought
that was odd oh that is weird i've met
him a couple times jimmy dore spoke at
at the event as well
the the event was was gutter trash it
was really bad thanks to con queso as
well as fast n for the twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 21 and 22. also
big thank you to andrew warren andrew
just gifted a one year subscription the
lucky recipient
is jody harper jody you get a free
membership you can keep we have now
658 people waiting for free memberships
you can gift them at joinpakman.com
and when you check out check the box
that says this is a gift
and that'll i'll announce you and i'll
announce who gets your membership also
thanks to bowflex man for the twitch
prime subscription uh a couple people
sent me some
reddit threads where people on other
um subreddits are
like discussing me and i thought this
might be interesting to look at let's
just see let's see if we have time i
think we do so
this one is from the jimmy dore
subreddit and someone there said what's
the appeal of pacman
can someone explain it to me oh hold on
do we
oh hold on a
second see if i can
get this
there we go okay
got it can someone explain it to me why
go to an indie youtube show to get your
news if the narrative you get is pretty
much the same as the establishment media
why go to him at all then and we will
ban men that's like going to a strip
club to get a lap dance from someone who
looks just like your current girlfriend
oh boy
okay and then the respondents say same
as sam cedar or the young turks i
stopped listening to those people during
obama
ditto everyone i know who listens to him
i guess they mean me is a russia gator
anti-rogan pro-israel lesser of two
evils ivor mecht in his horoscope
believing nutjob they keep telling me to
listen to him to get real news
unsubbed from all these clowns around
the time of the 2016 election hissy fit
they're all around [ __ ] lib trash chills
for biden and they smear anyone who
disagrees as a far-right conservative or
conspiracy theorist just sat all around
these people have never seen my show
right
there's big money and being an
unscrupulous shill
all right
so this is the view of some just a
couple of jimmy dore audience members
about me that's fair you know it's
interesting when i read this stuff
my mind goes to
i must be doing something right if i'm
repelling these people like i like that
these people don't like me
here's one from the
secular talk
kyle's subreddit
a user went and posted it's also sort of
like you're coming in here and
uh
like think also about
you go to other people's subreddits
and you post about me
like that's kind of weird right
okay anyway i don't really get why
people in this subreddit always
recommend david pakman as a viable
alternative to kyle
alternative is also interesting because
like are kyle's viewers looking for an
alternative i don't even know oh hold on
we've i've got to fix some of my things
here this is this is very unprofessional
there we go
the context is interesting like looking
for an alternative to me i don't know
okay for all of kyle's faults
he never smeared ilhan omar as an
anti-semite now of course i didn't do
that
what i said was
the rhetoric
that ilhan omar used
does play on an anti-semitic trope and i
did like 10 minutes on it
and i never say in the video ilhan omar
is anti-semitic but these things stick
to you like they just you can't get rid
of them he ran constant defense for
israel yes like unilaterally condemning
settlements
the netanyahu administration
for years i mean come on you know this
stuff is so old pacman did
for all of kyle's faults he never
promoted crypto scams for a quick buck
he refuses to take sponsors pacman
promotes them all the time and doesn't
own up to it like i've said a million
times before
we we sometimes do sponsored content we
label it as sponsored content i never
tell anyone to buy any crypto coin you
know it's like
it's the same stuff
for all of kyle's faults he was never
caught using view bots and comment bots
pacman was i don't even know what that's
about
now
there was that joke thing where sam
cedar was like pacman got to a million
first because of bots
but i don't i don't even know what that
means
pacman was caught using bots like i
don't know
for all of kyle's faults he never said
he liked cory booker and joe biden
pacman did pacman also ran defense for
warren and every single one of the oh
hold on are we missing the biden think
no we're not every single one of these
things
i don't know that anyone even cares to
look at it like i don't even i i'm i'm
making content here but i i it's like if
i had there's about 30 things here that
i would have to say so like what do i
mean when i say i like cory booker
i think he's a great speaker
and as an individual i know people who
know him and everybody has great things
to say
do i think he's the epitome of
progressivism no
have i said cory booker should run for
president the way i've said you know i
really like jamie raskin i'd be super
interested if jamie raskin ran for
president
i just think cory booker's a good
speaker and a good guy that's all i said
joe biden yes i said
when the primary started
that
back in 2012
joe biden really impressed me running
circles around paul ryan during the
debates
and biden i never said was the most
progressive candidate or any i mean are
these things that controversial like
biden made a great impression on me as
vp when he made paul ryan look like a
fool
okay
pacman ran defense for warren guys
elizabeth warren other than bernie is
literally one of the most progressive
members of the u.s senate
and i acknowledged that
her wealth tax proposal is one of the
most progressive economic policies
proposed by anyone in the senate
is that me running defense no it's me
saying hey guys you know
bernie is the most progressive at the
time bernie was the most progressive
and by my assessment
elizabeth warren was next
is
that's def guys
this is this is bad
then kyle has gone on the record to on
the record to say pacman always seemed
weirdly focused on money and numbers
when they hung out the few times they
did
i mean i don't know does anybody know if
his cut is that something kyle has
talked about i don't even know that i
don't know about that i mean
a lot of people might not know this but
when
a lot of us meet we don't talk about
politics like our we get our politics on
our shows
we often talk about like independent
media so you know you talk about yeah
like
how's revenue how's audience how you
know that's kind of like that's what
yeah that's
i i don't know if anybody knows about
kyle mentioning that i'd be interested
in seeing it and he clearly covers trump
way too much okay we've talked about it
yeah i mean like today we've got ten
segments on the show one has to do with
trump i don't know you know you guys
tell me if that's too much i'm sure
there's plenty i miss but yeah pacman is
bad bad vibes the this to me is more sad
than anything else
because it it is quite divisive
but it's also like kind of sad because i
imagine like all the people i personally
know it's hard to imagine anyone
spending their time
going on someone else's subreddit to
then post it like it's just kind of
weird like i don't know who who does
this type of thing
but um anyway i don't even know if we
want to go through the comments but
pacman's way too moderate
you know a lot of times when people call
in and they say that that you're way too
moderate i'll say okay like give me an
example of an issue on which i'm too
moderate
and they usually are like well like you
know you're not a socialist it's like
yeah guilty i'm not a socialist but like
give me an issue on which i'm too
moderate for you
yeah pretty standard uh
social democrat
um
let's do this kyle had a passion project
that ended up making him a living chose
not to go full businessman kept the vibe
like a passion project pacman had a
passion project that he ended making a
business he went full businessman that's
why he's so obsessed with the numbers
that's why kyle will always be better
than pacman to me kyle just does what he
likes to do
if they both lost everything kyle would
just keep
making videos after he got another
source of income pacman would just
search non-stop to make money and would
move on on if he couldn't
but yeah all right i mean you know it's
kind of speculative
anyway
so that's it's always interesting to see
kind of what's being said
in different uh subreddits it more bums
me out than anything else
because it's all kind of like
i don't know what we achieve with with a
lot of that stuff
um but for some people it's the type of
kind of
it's not even really like gossip per se
i don't know
let's look at some super chats mango
coin is headed to the moon
david sir if you're a shitlib amaya [ __ ]
lib by consuming your content
sue the machines we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines yeah
you were doing everything right in my
opinion never change screw the fake ass
idiot haters
whoa
that's pretty aggressive
that's pretty aggressive i want to say
thanks to meeted up
meeted up
is a new twitch prime subscriber and
number 25 today number 25.
we are standing by for joe biden he is
going to be delivering remarks here
on
record
inflation 8.5
over the last year
and what is he going to do to bring
prices down we're going to hear from him
momentarily
a bunch of comments from people saying
um
oh hold on where was it here
that was just a comment i wanted to read
and i lost it
oh god where was it here
oh man i missed it where was this going
oh okay
yeah anyway it doesn't matter
i want to say a huge thank you to aaron
vaughn aaron just got a gift membership
at joinpakman.com aaron has gifted a
membership i am giving that one to the
next person in line
vince lips vince lips there are now
659 people waiting for a free membership
if you want a free membership to my
website go to davidpakman.com free
membership
if you are in the privileged position
where you can gift someone a membership
just go to joinpakman.com
and when you're checking out check the
box that says this is a gift i would
actually love it
if you first got yourself a membership
that that's sort of like step number one
you see that you can go to
joinpackman.com
there's this coupon code obama
which you can use to get a discount get
yourself it's sort of like on a plane
where they say if the oxygen masks drop
uh put yours on first
then help other people
get yourself a membership first get in
the system
then start giving them out
uh oh yeah people asking about this
thing
so this is the weirdest thing
my i flew back from vegas a few days ago
and my mask cut my nose
it was really weird i didn't know
it was even possible must be some kind
of user error
but uh yeah i got a cut on my nose from
my mask
and uh it's mostly healed now
but it was it was weird really really
very very strange stuff
other super chats coming in
um
oh wow the phantom menace
with by far our top
super chat of the day
99.99 disregard haters no one's perfect
except maybe me
keep doing your thing playboy thank you
phantom menace that's incredibly
generous of you
a twitch user is asking have i seen the
obama meme on kimmel i did
so
um let me see if i can find it
i have i've completely lost control of
obama let me see if i can even find it
uh
kimmel obama
there's a realtor i worked with once who
would say you know here's the thing
you've got to
control the listing if you want a shot
at the property you have to control the
property once you lose control of it
it's over
and um i have lost control of obama i
think here it is
anonymous
really an anonymous
obama
administration
amnesty obama
what kind of president needs a note card
to answer a basic and predictable
question in his hand on a white house
piece of stationery we're five
handwritten okay anyway so this is like
a compilation from jimmy kimmel and
kimmel has now b meme jacked
obama i've lost control of it guys we
all know it originated here but i have
completely lost control of it i it it's
the cat is out of the back i want to say
thanks to twitch user
indeciso which means
indecisive
an indecisive individual
who is new member number 27 today also
thanks to terry schwerin
who has just gifted a subscription that
is new member number 28 the lucky
recipient is dan daniels dan
you get a free membership
also want to say thanks to joel efroni
who has gotten himself a membership
number 29 today
really appreciate that really appreciate
your generosity and everybody does
everybody does
other super chats dustin wants an obama
obama andrew says sad that sam caught
covid hope he gets better soon maybe
while he's gone you can go steal the
rest of his panels i would consider that
it seems unfair to do it while he's sick
with kovid we we wish sam the best
and want him to be better asap
big thank you oh joel afroni after
getting himself a membership is gifting
one so is martin eckendall
those are new members 30 and 31 the
lucky recipients are
dustin de la torre
and david littlejohn david little i knew
it david littlejohn actually i worked
with one i wonder if that's the same
person
i very much appreciate that thanks guys
lot we are now up to let's see 117
plus eight okay we we've now gifted 125
memberships on the website which is nuts
it's crazy
all right do we want to look a little
bit at this jimmy dore ivermectin clip i
have not reviewed this video yet
uh oh thanks commonsighter for the
twitch prime subscription what i'm told
is that even though at this point the
science is completely unequivocal if you
look just
at systematic reviews of randomized
controlled trials of ivermectin it
doesn't work for kovid i guess jimmy
dore is playing up that there's a
controversy let's just check out a few
minutes of this
because
uh i guess there was some new study now
not i guess there i know there was some
new study i saw the article in the new
york times we're going to get to it
and um
but i don't want to bury the lead
there's a larger study out of brazil
okay
the brazil study is
it's horseshit
i'm sorry guys but the brazil so
i've already talked about the brazil
study the way the brazil study was
organized was
they just gave people ivermectin in the
if i recall correctly
they just went into the community and
gave people ivermectin
they don't know who actually took the
ivermectin
they don't know if the people who took
it
took it
in the same doses
uh
they just
gave ivermectin to people
and then retrospectively they were like
who got coveted who took the ivermectin
oh yeah the ivermectin worked
that's not science guys
so i don't even know what jimmy's going
to say but
you can't compare the brazil study
to real science
you just can't i mean you can but you
look very dumb when you do it
and dr john campbell is going to tell us
a little bit about it right now okay so
i'm going to skip the campbell stuff
because i've already talked to you guys
about the uh
uh oh and now he's putting it up yeah
i've already done a deep dive onto this
study so here's the study here it's peer
reviewed um
so now of course peer review doesn't
mean it was properly done and okay all
right let's see and they don't do them
and why don't they do them because
there's no money in it that's so so
that's you hear that all the time
you hear
listen all this stuff might work really
well
but they won't study it because there's
no money in it and then you look and
there's a bunch of studies
it's come on because ivermectin is cheap
to produce pennies
it's weird because
i've i haven't watched a jimmy dore clip
in so long
but the stuff he's talking about we
debunked
nine months ago
and so it's weird to me where like
if you can get away with these talking
points it means your audience is really
ignorant because like my i'm not i'm not
blowing smoke up you guys uh any
anything i'm not blowing smoke anywhere
would any any any place you think i
might blow smoke i'm not blowing it
but
you
uh oh
do we have people anti-science cyber
mectin people in the chat i don't know
if we have to ban on that
i'll let the moderators decide because
at this point it's just it ivermectin's
been disproven
if i use these talking points with you
guys tell me if i'm wrong my instinct is
you all would know that these studies
are no that these talking points are no
good if i said to you guys
they won't study ivermectin because
there's no money in it like that's a
nine month old talking point that we've
debunked i don't think you guys would
fall for that so this does make me
wonder who is in dorae's audience that
they would still fall for this per dose
so that's why it were two years into
this and we still don't have studies
we have studies on vitamin d
we have studies on hydroxychloroquine we
have studies on ivermectin we have
studies on azithromycin these are all
cheap things and we have studies about
all of them
because they won't but the people who
have the money to fund the big ones
won't do it it's weird like does he even
believe this talking point or does he
just know his audience will fall for it
i genuinely don't know
um
just see here
uh i'm just looking
see what i can find
um
see if i can find a good one
no this one's too complicated but okay
anyway
if you google
covid hydroxychloroquine randomized
controlled trial you'll you'll find a
ton of them if you google vitamin d
covid randomize controlled trial all of
this stuff is being studied and so it's
it's interesting how
these guys will say
they don't want you to do this because
there's no money in it
it sounds like jimmy dore doesn't want
you to know that it's all been studied
all right let's continue but wait till
you get to this brazil study that dr
john campbell talks about
and uh
but first i want to get to this
because this is the thing that's got
everybody a buzz
ivermectin does not this is from the new
york times this is from a son of a gun i
didn't put the date on it
uh ivermectin does not reduce risk of
covet hospitalization large study
finds uh at some point it will become a
waste of resources to continue studying
an unpromising approach so that's called
propaganda
okay
because they're pretending like we've
been spending tons of money studying
this and they haven't
so understand that this is
when when it says waste of resources
i don't i don't think about it as money
i
i mean
when when you say waste of resources i
think well
it's a waste of medical resources where
you could be comparing the standard of
care to other things rather than another
study comparing the standard of care to
ivermectin
it the i mean
he's making he's that's not even what
it's saying
so by the way he also just told us there
were no studies on ivermectin and now he
found one but he says it's wrong that's
called propaganda and of course it's
coming from the new york times
it's not it's not propaganda right i
mean as people are pointing out lab time
resources statistical time
gives their gets their money from big
pharma i saw a stat the other day by the
way gets their money from big pharma
does jimmy not know that when you look
at a study it lists the conflicts that
the people have
so
could a study be biased by big pharma
sure
sure
you can look at conflicts and if you
believe that the authors of the studies
are lying
you can google them you can research the
authors and find out did they did they
hide a conflict i'm not even going to do
more of this because it's so stupid i
didn't think i when i when someone said
you should look at this because jimmy
dore is still pushing on this i didn't
realize it was this dumb
i you know sometimes viewers will write
to me saying they like jimmy dore and
they like me
and they watch both i don't understand
how anyone in my audience who
understands what i do
could see that clip and stay in jimmy
dore's audience i just don't
i just don't because that's one of the
mo it's either complete ignorance like
either jimmy has missed the last nine
months of research
or he's just lying like maybe he knows
that what he's saying is bogus and that
the brazil studies been debunked and
that yeah i have no idea
i genuinely have no idea i regret
looking at that because it's so
weaponized
uh thanks to
rich e fino and family media for the
twitch prime subscriptions putting us at
35
i am thrilled to tell you that i have
one two three four
five subscriptions to give away
thanks to kelly larabee
walter franco
dave lembo
dustin mason for gifting two that puts
us at 40.
the five lucky recipients are in order
of request
logan dinner
carol hanau
cathy colwell helena palancagus
and melissa smith
five gifted memberships i've just given
away five more cindy axne oh
okay here we go
[Applause]
okay we'll just monitor this until until
joe biden actually starts um if you
would like to get a free membership just
go to davidpakman.com
free membership and request one if you
are able to gift a membership go to
joinpakman.com and check that this is a
gift box as you go through the checkout
process also thank you to erin vaughn
who got herself a membership number 41
that's aaron listen
you deserve it
you did some gifting
you deserve to get yourself a membership
as well i appreciate that uh oh people
want to listen okay that's fine and nail
for this year after year
[Applause]
because i always knew that we needed to
make biofuels a part of our clean energy
solution and we're doing that right here
in iowa
investing in biofuels not only helps
iowa's farmers and rural communities but
also lessens our nation's
reliance on fossil fuels and brings down
prices for iowa families president biden
knows that ethanol which is created
right here at poet bio processing
[Applause]
is significantly cheaper at the pump
reduces our carbon emissions and
provides good paying jobs like right
here at poet in menlo and so the
president is here to support that
and so i'm so immensely grateful for the
president's work in upholding the
renewable fuels standard and keeping
biofuel production going strong and i'm
thankful for all the investments
president biden has made in iowa in his
time in office
everyone needs to know how much that is
iowa as we know has more structurally
deficient bridges than any other state
in the nation and thanks to president
biden's leadership we've already
received 650 million dollars in new
funding for roads and bridges
[Applause]
and over the next five years iowa is
expected to receive more than five
billion dollars from the infrastructure
investment act which helped to expand
the des moines airport repair pesky
potholes and make sure that bridges can
bear enough weight so our farmers can
get their goods to market and we're also
getting poisonous lead out of our
drinking water and so much more right
here in iowa and i'm so proud to be a
part of that i'm really proud to have
supported these investments that will
help keep iowa happy and healthy and to
make sure that we right here in iowa
have a fair shot at the 21st century
economy and i'm excited to see the
impact that these investments will have
in our great state
thank you all again so much for coming
out here today and thank you president
biden for your leadership with that i'm
going to turn it over to two wonderful
people rachel connor who is the green
merchandiser here at poet and joe biden
president of the united states of
america there you go
[Music]
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines
[Music]
whoa quite an intro huh
[Music]
what's really going on
[Music]
it's really great to be here with all of
you today my name is rachel connor and
i'm a grain merchandiser here at the po
at menlo location
what that means is that i help purchase
all of the grain in the bins from nearby
farmers
and it's truly the honor of a lifetime
to welcome president joe biden
and all of our distinguished guests to
poet today
i am a fifth generation farmer who is
born and raised right here in iowa
i've spent countless hours on the farm
driving a tractor and many more in
college and grad school studying
agronomy
these days i drive nearly 100 miles
round trip to work here at poet where we
make plant-based biofuels nutritious
feed
and a growing number of renewable
co-products
i'm excited to be part of a company and
an industry that's doing its part to
make the world a better place
since i'll be headed back home about 50
miles tonight you can bet that i'll be
fueling up with e-15
okay yeah fine but we got to get off of
this stuff all together and get on
electric and come june 1st i hope to
keep saving money with e15
many of you may recall when president
biden campaigned here in iowa he
promised to support biofuels
grow green jobs and cultivate a
low-carbon economy
today america is battling putin's price
hike
and mr president i can tell you our
nation's entire biofuels industry stands
ready to help
so ladies and gentlemen let's give a
warm iowa welcome to president joe
[Applause]
biden thank you very very much
now as i was campaigning here and i made
that commitment
i don't think anybody heard it but we're
back
we're back and i uh my name is joe joe
biden i work for
uh congressman axne
there she is
i learned a long time ago when she says
i have a i just say yes
i say yes right off the bat
i tell you what
she is one hell of a champion for you i
mean it i mean you ask anyone if you
ever come to washington
walk into the congress say you know
anybody from iowa the first thing
they'll say they'll mention her name
anyway said thank you thank you for your
friendship to start i'd like to say a
few words about
the mass shooting in new york city
subway this morning you've all read and
heard about
jill and i my wife jill and i are
praying for those that are injured and
all those touched by that trauma and
we're grateful for all the first
responders who jumped into action
including civilians civilians who didn't
hesitate to help their fellow passengers
and try to shield them my team has been
in touch with mayor adams and new york's
police commissioner
and the department of justice and the
fbi are working closely with the nypd on
the ground
adams has coveted right close contact
with new york authorities and as we
learn more about the situation over the
coming hours and days
and uh something could have broken
between now and the last hour i haven't
heard the news i haven't spoken any of
my staff but we're not letting up on it
till we find out and we find the the
perpetrator
now for the reason i'm here today
i want to thank you rachel and uh thank
you congresswoman axne uh when you hear
about progress we're making in iowa on
everything from biofuels to bridges you
can thank cindy that's what you know i'm
not joking
i am not a joke
there is no fence at the white house
high enough to keep her out
none
all kid aside said you're doing one heck
of a job thank you so much i also want
to say a special hello to someone who
really wanted to be here today and you
think i'm kidding he started he's the
guy that brought me to the first biofuel
plant in iowa years ago
your former governor of my secretary of
agriculture tom vilsack
unfortunately couldn't be here today
[Applause]
and he went to a press event in
washington and like two-thirds of the
people who went i think they got covert
he's doing fine spoke to him but uh he
couldn't be here but i'm here today to
talk about the work we're doing to lower
costs for american families and put
rural america
at the center of our efforts to build a
future that's made in america and that's
not hyperbole it's about being made in
america
a lot of that has has to do with this
industry
i just had a chance to see
the work you do here and turn more than
40 million bushels of local corn into
130 million gallons of ethanol a year
that's a lot of gallons we want to see
facilities like this all over the
midwest and here's why first it supports
farm it supports farmers and the farm
economy
you know everybody thinks delaware is a
big industrial state and banky state and
dupont
we have a four billion dollar industry
it's called agriculture in delaware
and it's mostly we have more chickens in
delaware broilers chickens than you have
in the entire midwest i think but all
kids aside it is a big industry in
delaware and my state everybody thinks
is a is an industrial state it's a very
rural state the largest city outside of
the main city of wilmington delaware is
a couple almost 150 000 people is 20 000
people it's a rural state to be honest i
think most people don't know anything
about delaware communities engaged in
being able to make a to be able to make
it generally
and all
all that corn in the silos is from
farmers within 60 miles of here
knowing you have a buyer gives farmers
something they don't often have
peace of mind
certitude about where their product can
be sold and to get a fair price for it
second it creates good-paying jobs it's
estimated there are over 400 000 jobs
directly and indirectly supported by
this industry nationwide there's a lot
of people that's a lot and a lot of
paychecks and good decent paychecks
third it reduces our reliance on foreign
oil by adding this fuel to our gasoline
[Applause]
10 or 15 even more stretches of supply
and fourth
it gives you a choice at the pump
when you have a choice
you have competition when you have
competition you have better prices
in addition to all that you get less
harm to the environment
lower greenhouse gas emissions and you
get even byproducts like grain here
which does goes into animal feed which
helps cattle producers and lowers their
cars
this is an industry with a tremendous
future
i've set a goal of zero carbon for
aviation sector for example by 2050
i've spoken with the leading heads of
all major airlines it's going to require
billions of gallons of sustain i
actually read a super interesting
article on my flight the other day about
how um electric planes for short flights
are probably only seven to eight years
away there's contracts in place there's
planes being manufactured for long-haul
flights it's going to be a lot longer a
little bit of biofuel it's where it's
called drop in meaning 100 biofuels you
don't need to take my word for it take
the word of the ceo of american airlines
who said sustainable aviation fuel is
the cornerstone of our strategy end of
quote
and the ceo of united airlines who
called the first biofuel-powered flight
a significant milestone for our efforts
to decarbonize our industry
to bring that future within reach i
propose a sustainable aviation fuel tax
that we brought together the
government's agencies aircraft
manufacturers airlines fuel producers
airports advanced cleaner and more
sustainable fuels for american aviation
that's how we're going to get there and
we can
we're in the cusp of so many significant
things are going to happen in this
country not just in the fuel side but in
the next 10 years
your children are going to see more
change in the next 10 years than we've
seen in the last 40 years that's how
rapidly technology's changing that'd be
great as far as aviation because a lot
has not changed for a long time about
aviation today because homegrown
biofuels have a role to play right now
right now as you work to get
as you work to get
prices under control and reduce the cost
for families look
i grew up in a family
not a joke where if the price of a
gallon of gasoline went up it was a
conversation at our kitchen table it
mattered it mattered with my mom and dad
it made a difference we felt it
putin's invasion of ukraine has driven
up gas prices and food prices all over
the world
the two largest grain producers in the
world china yeah it has but it also
predates what happened in in ukraine so
i mean it's
things going on
we saw today's inflation data
70
of the increase in prices in march came
from putin's price hike in gasoline 70
of the march increase that's important
to understand
that's why i've called on congress to
move immediately to lower the cost of
families utility bills prescription drug
bills and more while lowering the
deficit to reduce inflationary pressures
and that's what we've done we lowered
the debts by 300 billion dollars so far
as expected so folks
[Applause]
we can do these things without raising a
penny in tax on anybody in this in this
hall hall
yeah
in this giant barn
look
it's going to make a big difference for
families
you know it's the most impactful way
that congress can address inflation
right now but even as we work with
congress
i'm not going to wait to take action to
help american families i'm doing
everything within my power by executive
orders to bring down the price and
address the putin price site okay in
fact we've already made progress since
march inflation data was collected
your family budget your ability to fill
up your tank none of it should hinge on
whether a dictator declares war and
commits genocide a half a world away
to help deal with this putin price hike
i've authorized a release of 1 million
barrels per day for the next six months
from our strategic petroleum reserve so
that'll lower gas prices five to fifteen
cents per gallon i do think it's pretty
dishonest to be calling this the putin
price hike because this actually started
under trump and it's happening globally
and some of it has to do with putin
with partners and allies around the
world i've spent hours and hours of my
counterparts around the world trying to
get them into guys i get that he's doing
it on purpose i'm saying i think it's
not really accurate countries
agreed to release another 60 million
additional barrels out of the market
over 240 million barrels over the next
six months is the bridge
to be able to make sure we are going to
be able to keep prices down
this is the largest collective reserve
release in history
hundreds of hours of meetings of key
allies keeping them together is paying
off
putin
is was counting on the division of nato
the division of the european union
division of the world
we've spent a lot of time
but they're all following every single
one including in asia
south korea japan
australia
all of them nations coming together to
help deny putin the ability to weaponize
his energy resources against american
families families in europe and around
the world and by the way
we're also cutting off access to
technology for him
without american technology look at the
number of major
american companies on their own
not i'm out of my urge
over 600 of them from exxon to
mcdonald's have left
russia
left russia he has a burning tundra
literally
it's burning the permafrost is burning
he's got a problem
and he's caused we're not going to let
him cause that problem to spread to the
rest of the world
and that helps stop the run-up of oil
prices that have begun to bring prices
down a little bit as a result countries
acting together to release this reserve
and america should be seeing the savings
and we're not just learning and leaning
on our reserves and our allies and
partners to help bring down
gas prices and to power the nation we're
leaning on you
our farmers our biofuel refineries
today
i'm announcing that the environmental
and i don't think as much of
announcement has already broken out
pretty much the last 24 hours but the
environmental protection agent is
planning to issue an emergency waiver
to allow e15 gasoline that uses more
ethanol from home-grown crops to be sold
across the united states this summer in
order to increase fuel supply
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
folks i mean that's not like crazy
exciting when you think about the long
term but i get that there's pressure to
do something short term
i feel like thank you
i feel like as
as as a minister and i feel like i'm
preaching to the choir here
but here's what it means
a15 is about 10 cents a gallon cheaper
than e10
and some gas stations offer an even
bigger discount than that now is e15
less efficient when you burn it i don't
know the answer i'm just wondering
because that would counter any price
difference i just don't know the answer
does anybody know
on june 1 you're not going to show up at
your local gas station and see a bag
over the pump that has the cheapest gas
you're going to be able to keep filling
up with e15
and it's going to stop it's three to
five percent less efficient seems to be
the consensus in the chat okay that's
interesting not going to solve all our
problems it's going to help some people
and i'm committed to whatever i can to
help
even if it's an extra buck or two in the
pockets that they fill up will make a
difference in people's lives and even
though a15 is only available in a few
thousand pumps today
we're investing more than 100 million
dollars to build biofuel infrastructure
for the future
things like blend pump blender pumps the
gas pumps that can handle higher blends
and bioethanol and diesel fuel
of course
there's more i mean what's depressing i
get that he's at a place that makes this
stuff so like he can't go
really eventually we got to put all of
y'all out of business and go to fully
electric i get that that wouldn't be
politically expedient but when you hear
him talking about e15 for the long term
it's like dude what are you talking
about that's not the solution that's
just not the future level the plane feel
for many family farmers and ranchers
because as many of you here know better
than anyone
that four big companies control more
than half the market for beef pork and
poultry giving ranchers very few choices
about who to sell to to get their
product
these big conglomerates drive down
prices they pay farmers and even as they
drive up prices at the grocery store
so we're investing up to 1 billion
dollars in american rescue funds for new
and expanded meat and poultry processing
capacity throughout this country
[Applause]
and this is something i've talked about
with brent johnson who is here today
we're going to invest
in innovative new products
and processors
small businesses independent businesses
the lifeblood of our economy
it's going to give farmers and ranchers
more options to shore up a weak point in
our food supply chain and bring down
prices for american families
i've said it before and i say it again
i'm a capitalist but without capitalism
without competition isn't capitalism
it's exploitation
exploitation
and bringing down historic economic
progress
reducing costs for families also
requires investing in infrastructure
my introducer's going to drive home 50
miles i got to make sure of the
thousands of bridges in this state and
around the country that aren't safe i
hope you're not going over some of them
and that starts with roads and bridges
it really does
as cindy's pointed out iowa has more
bridges than any other state in the
nation that are classified as
structurally deficient
four thousand
five hundred are in poor condition
and here's the reason why cindy's work
in the infrastructure law was so
important
about two-thirds of the bridges in need
of repair
in this country
are considered off system
because they did not directly on the
interstate highway system
back in january
i was supposed to speak in pittsburgh
which i did
at a steel mill but on the way there
a bridge collapsed in the city
that's what most people don't realize
it's called the city of bridges there's
more bridges in pittsburgh than any
other city in america
and it was and that morning i got there
it collapsed we went straight to the
site
and the bridge had been written in poor
condition for the last 10 years
thank god nobody died
it was about i'm guessing
maybe 300 yards across a little bit of a
valley and a shallow creek and the
steepest part from the bridge to this
creek was probably about
eight or ten stories
and it was a snow day
and that bridge if it weren't a snow day
would have had at the moment it went
down
school buses with hundreds of kids going
across that bridge
this stuff matters
i mean it really matters i was telling
cindy back in i was in small town in
western pennsylvania
and they needed a bridge of the bridge
was only as far as from the length of
not half the length of this this room
and guess what
the fire station was on one side and the
town was on the other
but because they couldn't take the fire
trucks across that bridge because
they're afraid it would collapse
they had to go if i'm not mistaken it's
either 10 or 11 miles
five and a half miles up and five and a
half miles back to get there
and they had a fire
and they couldn't get there in time
just across they could see it it was
literally
anybody know where this is going i don't
know
they couldn't do anything about it these
bridges are essential
for small towns in my state and your
towns and rural areas
for farmers to get their products to
market for small businesses to be able
to serve their customers
these are bridges that when they're
closed
shifts off delivery and routes to
schools and boots home it takes a lot
longer
they create longer delays for first
responders
when every second counts
and you all cindy can cite it for you
the statistics are you get in an
accident in a rural area
you have about a 40 percent greater
chance of being certain dying than you
do if it happens in the city it just
simply takes longer to get to the
hospital
longer to get to the dock
so the bipartisan infrastructure bill we
included
27.5 billion dollars
for smaller bridges including dedicated
funding for off system bridges
and folks look we used to be rated the
number one infrastructure had the number
one infrastructure in the world
we're now number eight the united states
of america
the united states of america
and folks here in iowa
our bipartisan infrastructure law is
delivering 93 million dollars for those
bridges just this year
93 million
at least 14 million for off system
bridges this year
look this investment's going to help
connect entire towns and regions and new
opportunities
we've gone from waiting for
infrastructure week
now you got infrastructure
infrastructure a decade
10 years
10 years
and we owe it to you
look it's going to help workers get jobs
good paying jobs products get to market
reduce costs for families
with this investment we're sending the
message
to america's small communities
and the people who call your call you
home
this home
you matter you matter we see you
not a joke
and we're building back with you
we're making sure
you're not left out or left behind
we're also investing in universal
affordable high-speed internet
i was surprised at this number i have to
tell you sixteen percent of iowa
households don't have an internet
subscription
in some places there's no high-speed
internet infrastructure at all
zero in this state
and the law will make high-speed
internet affordable available everywhere
in iowa
and think of what that will make
possible from telemedicine to precision
agriculture to small businesses that
want to be able to sell in bigger
markets
in the 21st century in america
no parent ever should have to pull into
mcdonald's or a fast food chain
to literally hook up to the internet in
their car so the kid could do their
homework over on the line true think
about that the united states america
we're the guys that came up with all
this stuff
our infrastructure law invests in clean
water and wastewater systems including
the major investment on luna and lewis
and clark rural water system to bring
clean reliable drinking water to more
than 350 000 people in south dakota to
minnesota to northwest iowa it matters
it matters of the health that matters
that convenes and matters across the
board
we're investing in ports and waterways
including over 700 million dollars
for a lock and damp project 25 on the
mississippi you say what does that have
to do with me has a lot to do with y'all
because nearly every bushel of soybean
and corn that is transported on that
river from illinois iowa minnesota
missouri wisconsin goes through these
locks
and they were built in 1930
1930s barges often need to be split into
smaller groups to make it through
taking hours and sometimes greater
delays
with new modern locks we're going to
help farmers get their products to
market faster more efficiently lower
cost and keep american hackers are
globally competitive
folks the list goes on i'm starting to
bore myself here but this is important
stuff
i think i think he's boring himself in
fact
members of my administration and i will
be visiting rural america
in over 25 states over the next three
weeks to talk about
how we can do even more to create jobs
and opportunity
to make sure that the investments we're
making reach rural communities
buy from rural businesses create jobs
here at home
giving your young people the opportunity
to make a living and raise a family in
the place where they were raised where
they want to stay
[Applause]
i won't ask the people i know no woman
is over 50 years of age here but the men
are 50.
how many times
have you had a son or daughter niece or
nephew say i don't want to move but i
have to there's no job here
i don't have a chance here
we're changing that
let me close with this
when i was running for office i heard it
a thousand times
we're going to build an economy around
you
the communities who feed and fuel our
nation
well we are
we are
we're going to deal in people in places
that had been left out and left behind
for a long time
are making progress
over the course of my presidency
our recovery has now created 7.9 million
jobs in almost 17 my 14 months
[Applause]
more jobs created over the first 14
months of any president in american
history
and by 2021
our economy created more jobs in rural
america
than occurred in the last 15 years
so i'm more optimistic about america
today than i've been in my whole life
right i uh my doc i had a i had an
aneurysm when i was much younger
and i was put in the hospital as a
senator
and he started explaining to me what an
aneurysm was i said i don't need to know
he said i'm just going to just take top
your head off and do something with it
and i said no you do your job i'll do
mine i'll be the patient
and after it was all over he said you
know what your problem is senator of the
senator i said no he said you're a
congenital optimist
and i am because i'm an american
that's why i'm optimistic because i see
a future that's within our grasp no
hyperbole
we're the only nation on earth
this is not pure chauvinism this is a
truth we're the only nation on earth if
you think about it
that's come out of every major crisis
stronger than when we went in we just
didn't go back to where we were we came
out stronger
stronger literally every major crisis
if we faced we turned into an
opportunity
that's exactly what we're going to do
today
with all of you
i i can't thank you enough for your
all the work you put in
all the faith you have in your state
your community your country
and uh
i just want to say god bless you all and
every time i walk out of my grandpa
finnegan's house up in scrant which died
when cole died it's coming back
every time
you walk out the door and you go
joey keep the faith
and then one of my my grandmother and my
aunt would yell no joey spread it let's
go spread the faith thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
wow well not not the most uh high-energy
event we've we've ever seen uh i guess
but
interesting i don't know that anything
new was proposed i mean he has already
opened the strategic petroleum reserve
so i just i just don't know
how much we learned
but it was certainly interesting to see
uh the speech
i do need to ask you guys for a favor it
has come to my attention that there are
some individuals
lobbying am 950 which was one of our
major radio affiliates in minnesota to
drop the david pakman show there's a
small group contacting them and saying
please end the david pakman show
and it would be really great that's a
big affiliate for us it would be really
great
if you guys emailed and said
thanks for having the david pakman show
on your station
uh you can go to am950radio.com
and there's a big contact button it
wouldn't be appropriate for me to give
you anyone's emails but if you can do me
the favor you go to am950radio.com
there's a contact button and it very
clearly tells you how to contact the
station
all you have to do is say hey thanks for
running the david pakman show we love it
we think it's the best we think it's
great we think it's good you know
whatever you don't have to say it's the
best uh we don't want to allow a small
group of
activists who are detractors
to uh successfully convince am950 to
drop the show i don't know that they
would
but it would be great to get a little
counterpoint there
uh it's an independent station i believe
they are not like part of a big
conglomerate so you're literally
emailing the people
okay
all right very good thank you to
everyone for joining me thank you thank
you thank you
joe biden will hang and chat a little
bit i'm gonna run i'm actually this is
the this is great
i'm being interviewed in a little bit
by a 13 year old for his youtube channel
he's got a great political youtube
channel i'll tell you more about it
after the interview's done
i think this is going to be a really
really interesting interview
all right so i'm going to run and do
that and then we'll post it to our
youtube channel when it's up all right
everybody see you soon thank you for
joining me